two years ago in 2021 I tested magnus's
memory by setting up a bunch of famous
positions and seeing whether he could
recognize them
[Music]
obviously now we're going to do the same
but with an added twist we're not even
going to be able to see which pieces are
which every piece will be represented by
an air things device instead so let's
see how Magnus gets on
so Magnus
easy start first position
what do you think of of this yeah first
of all I'm thinking like what are all
these pawns on the
on the last rank but if I'm going to go
piece by piece I'm hoping that this is a
king
and these are pawns and that this is a
bishop
this is a rook this is a rook and this
is a queen and hopefully Queen H6 should
be made in two
and hopefully that's enough to win a
world championship title exactly 2016
right yes Carlson against karyakin World
Championship
he's good
[Music]
position two will Magnus find this any
tougher
okay he's thinking this is no I I'm
waiting for the camera oh
I thought I got him
so this test is called has Magnus been
following the world championship and uh
the answer is
not like a resounding yes or anything
but it's the answer is enough to know
that this is I don't remember which
match game but anyway it was a ding is
White against the promise here and here
he could have taken the Rook with the
queen and then
once you start giving these checks
eventually
the queen goes back here uh King to D2
Green Bay two King B3
Bluetooth Cherokee four takes
king of three and eventually the king is
running away or even
but yeah oh impressive even Bishop D3
actually yeah this is oh maybe not maybe
not Bishop
maybe not queen king of three I just
assumed it was king of three but yeah
Bishop D3 actually works that's easier
than I thought actually I think should
have found this one
you heard it here first Magnus does
follow the 2023 world championship and
he does have great pattern recognition
[Music]
so Magnus uh position three
is this any more difficult for you no
not really the games are too famous
that's the problem
well this has to be a casparov tupalo
from 99 in RS what characteristics make
you recognize this position
maybe like it's just the structure on
the queen side
first I was thinking oh this is some
kind of Rue Lopez and then
yeah then I just thought you know
what is this is this a bishop oh no it's
actually the king that makes makes more
sense but yeah I think the game was just
to be famous too famous otherwise it
would have been would have harder I
thought it might cut you off guard that
King but I thought the giveaway might be
this uh this one can't be many pieces I
guess actually actually it is because
you won't ever have doubled plants there
1999 we were kids at the time yeah
so like these are ponds
this is oh he's thinking first time in a
while
it's not a pressure business
oh is this the queen actually if you
think about what this one is it might
give it away
oh yeah so that's a queen and this is a
queen and he played Rook
Rook D4 Brook T4 CD4
rookie seven so here again you could
probably have taken taken on
this is yeah this is super confusing
yeah rookie seven King
B6 takes D4
okay fine famous kinghunt
so um I I can't even remember okay B4
King
F4
did it immediately no Queen C3 first I
guess yeah you got it Queen C3
[Music]
black needs to defend against this
Checkmate threat without being the king
what is that oh the bishop is on age
three the bishop is on age three and
that's a Pawn on H2 yeah that makes
sense
so I think he took the question yeah
to avoid uh Bishop D5 King B2 is
immediately over let me see I took with
the queen
uh then okay seven yeah yeah yeah yep
yeah
thanks yeah
it's remembering like a 10 move sequence
from a game that wasn't his from
25 years ago I'm trying
yeah I still had to find like a lot of
good most Quincy for so far yep
there's a lot of bad things devices in
his hands
oh he takes an F6 yeah it takes an F6
nice
[Music]
take this one
black has to take here yeah black has to
take here then you give a check
I guess no that's a different line it's
complicated I guess part of one
yeah it's really complicated yeah
I think he took an A6 and one C3 either
way oh thickness Magnus succeeds again
[Applause]
[Music]
so Magnus is impressed so far but uh how
will he get on with this position yeah
so this one is one of uh one of my
happier uh early chess chess memories is
from the world's youth
Championship under 14. I'm playing Black
in the uh on in the first round against
future Grandmaster at this point uh your
music Hammer so that's this isn't this
is a night
um this is a rook and this is a queen
and this is a pawn and that's the king
over there
um and this is not Rook or queen so
that's pretty much all I think or and
that's the problem I think that's pretty
much
to know so that's how you recognize this
pattern
to know that this
and this this checkmates
is that called Anastasia's mates
I think so yeah was it this Knight that
gave it away yes this piece that's the
one who gave it away we could order
things device
yeah every time yeah every time there's
a device let's say in the place
suspiciously in the other in the other
camp and
sort of narrows it down especially if
it's um if it's a well-known game
yeah well done I was trying to catch you
up but it's always these one pieces that
give it away
[Music]
so this is the final position I'm going
to test Magnus out on I'm really hoping
to catch him out here
damn this looks like Checkers except
except while it can't be Checkers
because
um not all the pieces are on the same
color complex but
got him thinking
but it's definitely the game I've seen
now
almost it's I don't want to give it away
but it you will have that's the clue you
will have seen it so the hardest one is
the one with the fewest pieces yes
fewer hints recognizing the patterns
right
oh
no that's not it
in this position white played this
and it was a mistake
I'm not sure I've actually seen this
black played this
and then
and white resigned
white resigned like okay so it's
obviously a king
okay sorry about this it's my bad it's
from the Queen's Gambit TV show when
Beth plays what's his name towns in the
first her first ever tournament oh oh
so what and this is a rook and it's
trapped now because there's a nice and
deep Warner King on D2 yeah yeah
this uh this rocket is actually trapped
in this yeah and this is upon us so it
blocks the Escape as this why did I
think this was the key roof okay yeah
that makes sense yeah I remember that
sequence from from the series now but
like it was
not close to front of from I think if
you'd seen the pieces you would have got
it right yeah things devices yeah yeah
then this makes it tricky yeah no that
was I was not close to this one but the
the final position is quite quite nice
though you heard it here first he's
human but uh still very impressive thank
you Magnus
okay